so i know that i'm showing up as tom
um i wasn't able to change it um
my real name is cinderlin stud and you
know why i was called tom in the first
place that's a whole different story so
that's for another time um i'm going to
talk about
um the year 2038
problem um i work for a company called
intuit or
one trip in english we work with public
transportation
systems and we'll do a lot of really
cool stuff
um but um the
thought of the year 2038 problem that i
just came across in an article really
got me thinking about a different type
of travel
namely time travel because i figured
that the year 2038 problem would be a
real issue
to them um and i'm gonna explain that in
in a few minutes um
but there's you know i had to make some
i had to cut some corners to sort of
make the year 2008
problem fit into this um
this case so i'm gonna have to ask you
to just go along with it even though it
doesn't make a lot of sense
um and you know don't worry even if it
doesn't make sense and it doesn't seem
like there's some logic to it
don't worry because where we're going we
don't need logic
and that's a movie reference
if we go back to the year 1985 um
and the month of october it was a really
interesting month a lot of really cool
stuff happened
first of all the i386 processor from
intel came out which was the first
generally available 32-bit processor
on the market that same year
dr emmett brown also invented the time
machine
and it was covered in great detail in
the documentary film series
back to the future so i'm sure of you um
like many of you have probably
seen it before um you should probably
also know then that
einstein was the world's first time
traveler and for those who don't
remember einstein was dr edward brown's
dog
the machine that they would travel
in time with was based on a gmc delorean
it has a stainless steel body which is a
really good quality when you're fitting
it with a flux capacitor
which is like the main device that makes
time travel possible
the downside to the flux capacitor is
that it requires a lot of power
like you have to feed it 1.21 gigawatts
for it to work
and to solve that he had to fit um a
nuclear reactor
as a power source into the vehicle later
he fitted a mr fusion home energy
reactor but
you know for this case we'll just stick
with the plutonium
so how it works is you would add one
pellet of plutonium
and one pellet of plutonium would be
enough for one trip
then there's an input panel inside the
vehicle where you would enter
the time of your arrival
and let's say that in this case we want
to go to october 21st
2015 and we set the time
then we accelerate to 88 miles an hour
then bam like in a flash you just
suddenly disappear
um and then you're you're gone because
you're you're off
traveling in time you could travel um
into the future into the past
it certainly was a very uh impressive
invention
dr emmett brown was certainly a genius
but we do know that he has some flaws
um like we know that he did conduct a
lot of really dangerous experiments in
public
like he did some of the first attempts
of time travel were done
at a at a mall um so it really like
endangered the public
and it would certainly also make him
very prone to theft
like a lot of people would probably be
able to just see and steal his tech
so we can assume that people will be
able to copy it he was also affiliated
with known criminals
um he got the plutonium off of libyan
terrorists
so he certainly had some some sketchy
connections
judging from his workspace we could
probably assume that he was severely
disorganized
and judging from his craftsmanship when
you look at his inventions
we can probably assume that he's very
prone to taking some shortcuts
and if we take all these factors into
consideration we could also
conclude that he probably doesn't unit
test
so let's take a look at um how he might
have implemented some of
the control systems on board um so
this is the algorithm well let's say
he's written in c
and is using the time t data type um
that uses uh 32-bit signed ins
um so the algorithm here is basically
that it fetches
the input from the input panel well year
month day hour and minute of the arrival
time
and then um goes into a while loop
um where that input is um well you have
the
the arrival time as a timestamp and then
in a in an infinite loop you just match
that with the current
timestamp and if it matches you break
out of the loop
and then you stop the flux capacitor and
as you
stop the capacitor um you arrive safely
at that point in time where you wanted
to um to go
um now this is obviously very basic and
you know it doesn't handle errors very
well and he's using the time t
data type which is using a 32-bit signed
end which has a maximum
value of around 2.1 billion
and we know that unix timestamp is the
number of seconds since
january first 1917.
we can tell that the furthest you could
travel into the future
if you're using a timestamp like this is
um
to january 19 2038.
now what happens when that int overflows
is that just keeps
you know um let's say it's an
incremental count it just when it hits
that limit it will in most systems
will depends a bit on the implementation
but on most systems it will just turn
into a negative number where you start
from the
the um the minimum value which means as
you're hitting
2038 um you will basically get thrown
back to a timestamp that represents 1901
now this is obviously an issue as you're
traveling in time
um so if you're taking some shortcuts
and you're using
the unix timestamps for this and
let's say you're in 1985 you've stolen
or copied
dr emmett's brown invention it's um you
even have a source code everything is
running exactly as he would
and you have one palette of plutonium
like but like even if you just get one
uh plutonium that's quite impressive
because you know plutonium is very hard
to get by
but you figure that you're going into
the future anyway right so
in the future everybody has plutonium so
it's not going to be an issue
and you don't want to go like you don't
want to go to 2015 you want to go
into the proper future you want to see
flying cars
so you want to go to 2050 right
now i'm sure many of you um can catch
where this is going right
um in a worst case scenario where
the overflow isn't handled very well and
the algorithm just keeps on going like
the numbers will never match
you will essentially just be sent off um
into
nothingness um you will basically be
lost in time never to return
in a best case scenario the overflow is
handled
but you know it will flow over and then
start back at the minimum value and
count upwards
and then you'll effectively end back in
now you only brought one palette of
plutonium so that means you're probably
not making it back
that also means that there's you know um
somewhat likely that somewhere around
maybe 1914 or maybe around the 1910s
there's a group of really disgruntled
and disappointed
scientists who never managed to get back
to 1985.
now this is what we call the year 2038
problem or the unix y2k
and the reason why it's called the unix
y2k is because it's very similar to the
y2k
issue that we all know i just want to
say that
one of the reasons why the y2k issue
didn't have the grave consequences that
many
said it would have was because a lot of
people put in a lot of effort to
fix vulnerabilities in systems so it
wasn't something that just fixed itself
and perhaps this is something that we
should you know take it to consider
consideration when we're talking about
the 2038 problem as well
but if we fast forward into the present
um you know certainly this is not an
issue anymore right
like we've got 64-bit systems and all
sorts of data types that can handle
like any number thinkable
but there are still some examples uh say
with the boeing 787
it turns out a few years ago that it had
an um
an issue that if it ran for 248
consecutive days without being shut down
the generators would fail
and if you do the math um if you look at
a maximum value of a 32-bit signed in
that's about 2.1 billion
and then you let's say it's you know
probably some sort of embedded system
that has like a 10 millisecond tick
count or something
um so we count it in centi seconds and
then two days we'll see that that's
roughly 248 days and that's certainly
not a coincidence so
um even in like really expensive and
large
machines like this we can find issues
like this
another example is the unix timestamp
function
that's in several um sql languages
um if you go past the year 2038 and
january 19 you will just
um get a zero in return i
pulled the latest version of my sequel
to to see if it still
applies and it still does so if you have
some sort of queries running in
production that's going to last
for the next like 15 16 or 17 years um
you should probably you know have a look
at them
now this has been known for a long time
that uh my sequel thing
it was first posted on the mysql um
um ticketing um forum about
in like 2005. um it still hasn't been
fixed
um now the bad thing is that it hasn't
been fixed but the good thing is that we
now can blame oracle for it
now it does have some real-life uh
complications as well
um in say you know medical equipment
in banking in embedded control systems
for you know water plants or or anything
um this could be an issue as well as
military devices
you know if you're launching launching a
rocket
that might affect where it would land
so what do we learn from this um
[Music]
the take-homes are that you have to be
aware of
data type limits like even today even
though we
have a range of different data types
that we can choose from
make sure that it doesn't bite you check
your sql queries so you don't use the
unix time sound function where you
shouldn't
remember to reboot your airplanes or the
generators will fail
and if you're going to travel in time
you should always take some extra
plutonium
because you never know when you might
get stuck at some point in time and
you're unable to get back
and that's it thank you very much